a number of you sent me a clip of
congresswoman Corey Bush claiming that
red states have higher rates of murder
and higher rates of gun deaths and that
is absolutely true and I'm going to go
over some of the data with you now this
is relevant because the story that the
right loves to tell is how red states
are safer and red cities are safer and
blue States and blue cities run by
democrats are just riddled with crime
and they're dangerous and that's really
where all of the violence is let's first
listen to what Corey Bush said then
we're going to look at some of this data
in 2020 per capita murder rates were 40
percent higher in States won by Donald
Trump than those won by Joe Biden nine
of the ten states with the highest gun
mortality rates including my state of
Missouri are red States
Mr Wilcox first of all thank you for
your strong well-informed advocacy
um I want to build on Mr nadler's
question can you explain how the iron
Pipeline and weak Republican laws of gun
laws disproportionately harm black and
brown communities
uh yes ranking member and thank you for
the question
um as as you stated what we see pretty
clearly from examining gun laws and
looking at rates of gun violence is
states with stronger gun laws see less
gun violence uh why is that it's because
it's too easy for guns to be illegally
diverted from legal Commerce responsible
law-abiding citizens into gun
trafficking channels what are the ways
that that happens no background check
gun sales straw purchasing okay so now
they go into a number of the ways in
which we could strengthen uh gun laws
but so is this the truth you know
anecdotally we keep hearing frequently
now when Republicans talk about New York
City the accurate statement that the
violence rate the violent crime rate is
higher in Oklahoma City than it is in
New York City Oklahoma City a red City
in a red State compared to New York City
a blue City in a blue state but this is
actually a bigger Trend so let's look at
a couple of different things if you look
at the 2020 homicide rate and if you're
looking there's a graph here where you
have states with the highest homicide
rates at the top right
and lower uh homicide rates as you go
down to the bottom left you see that the
states with the highest homicide rates
are Mississippi Louisiana Alabama
Missouri Arkansas South Carolina
Tennessee Maryland Illinois New Mexico
Georgia you have this gradient wherein
the homicide rates are notably higher in
red States you then go to Firearms
mortality
and you see a very similar story the
highest death rate from Firearms is
Mississippi Louisiana Wyoming Missouri
Alabama Alaska blue state of New Mexico
followed by Arkansas South Carolina
Tennessee Montana Oklahoma Kentucky West
Virginia Georgia Idaho Indiana Nevada
Kansas
finally getting to Arizona okay so there
is no doubt whatsoever that that is the
truth it doesn't matter how you slice
and dice the State numbers now how would
the right react to this well one of the
things that the right says when
presented with this information one of
the things they say is the numbers
aren't true it's fake news we can't
believe it it's all nonsense you made
that up okay if you can get them to
acknowledge these numbers
they will often say well but the crimes
are mostly in the cities within those
states which are blue
now that's not actually true it is true
as a general rule that people on the
left in the United States are more
likely to live in urban areas and people
on the right are more likely to choose
to live rurally and Suburban it's sort
of a mix depending on the states that
you're in that is absolutely true but in
general rates of crime uh can follow
where people are closer together but by
looking at rates we actually account for
that and there have been studies done
that say okay fine you can look at these
cities if you want
and there are very high numbers of
crimes because of the number of people
but you can chart these very large rural
areas that cross many states uh on a map
and as far as rates of crimes go they
are still very high in those rural areas
it's just that the absolute numbers are
lower because there are fewer people but
the truth is if we want to be more
serious about this there is no one
answer to this is it true that red
States on average having more relaxed
gun laws increases gun deaths yes it is
true and also it is true
that if you live in Chicago which is a
blue City in a blue state
which has strict gun laws you can very
easily drive 40 minutes over into
Indiana or what is it like 55 60 minutes
into Wisconsin potentially
states with more relaxed gun laws so it
it's not everything is Shades of Gray
the gun accessibility is a factor but it
also impacts blue states that are in
proximity to Red States poverty is a
major factor poverty is higher in red
States education is a factor education
is worse in red States cultural
attitudes towards using guns to solve
problems
I I'm I don't have data on what the
differences are between blue and red
States on that but it is a factor in a
if you had states where culturally it's
considered more appropriate to fight to
use physical violence or to use guns to
resolve interpersonal problems well
that's going to be a factor for sure
infrastructure and Economic Opportunity
which we know is lower in red States GDP
per capita lower in red States all of
these elements are factors and many of
them actually are sort of a feedback
loop where some cause others and in turn
the worsening of those others comes back
and worsens the initial causes proximate
and ultimate causes are definitely
something that needs to be considered
but the numbers really don't lie it
really is the case that gun mortality
rates remember rate accounts for
population the rates of gun mortality on
average higher in red States the murder
rate on average higher in red States
they don't like to admit it when they do
they find some other way to blame the
left but this is the reality in which we
live